Constitución
estos cambios eran necesarios para
asegurar la jubilación de cada uno y
para producir mayor riqueza para nuestra
nación porque en efecto mientras que
aumenta el número de jubilados y nuestra
esperanza de vida es cada vez mayor la
respuesta no podía ser disminuir las
pensiones tampoco podía ser aumentar las
cotizaciones de quienes trabajan y
tampoco podía ser como muchos lo han
dicho no hacer nada porque entonces era
dejar que se acumularán los déficits y
que aumentarán nuestras deudas para las
generaciones futuras estos cambios pues
eran necesarios Y sí es cierto
constituyen un esfuerzo pero está
acompañado de medidas de justicia de
mejoramiento concreto para quienes han
tenido carreras largas y quienes han
ejercido los
empleos más duros o que reciben o los
que reciben pequeñas pensiones
se está pidiendo que trabajen un poco
más como lo han hecho nuestros vecinos
europeos esto también es producir más
riqueza para todo nuestro país esto es
una inversión en nuestra vida cotidiana
y en nuestro futuro y de eso necesitamos
ahora es obvio que está reforma no es
bien aceptada
A pesar de los varios meses de
concertación no se pudo llegar a un
consenso y debemos sacar todas las
enseñanzas que esto trae en las
manifestaciones
una manifestación en contra de la
Reforma de las pensiones
también se pide que se mejoran las
carreras
o sea lo que se ha expresado en las
calles es una ira ira frente a un
trabajo que para muchos franceses ya no
permite una vida porque los precios
suben
porque a pesar de una movilización
inédita del estado en Europa el aumento
de los precios es algo que pesa en
nuestras vidas cotidianas esta ira
también es una ira Porque algunos tienen
la impresión que están haciendo lo que
deben hacer pero que sus esfuerzos no se
deben recompensados ni en ayudas ni en
servicios públicos eficaces toda esta
ira es la que muchos franceses han
expresado en las manifestaciones muchos
de ellos han manifestado en medio de la
Calma y el respeto de nuestras
instituciones pero a nadie ni menos yo
puede ser sordo
expresiones que hemos escuchado y sobre
todo de nuestra juventud la respuesta no
puede estar ni en el inmovilismo
frente a esta ira frente a esta
sensación de abandono y de
desplazamiento actuaremos
juntos Más allá de las divisiones como
siempre he querido hacerlo al servicio
de un rumbo claro el rumbo de nuestra
independencia y de la justicia primero
nuestra independencia primero para
Francia y para Europa Somos un pueblo
que
quiere elegir su destino no queremos
depender ni de las fuerzas de la
especulación ni de las potencias
extranjeras ni de voluntades distintas a
la nuestra en esto tenemos razón pero la
independencia no se decreta es algo que
se construye mediante ambiciones y
esfuerzos tanto a nivel nacional como
europeo en el campo de la atractividad
la tecnología la tecnología la defensa
también es algo que se financia
colectivamente a través del trabajo
esta Independencia francesa y europea es
justamente la que nos va a permitir
obtener más justicia que cada uno
cosecha más de sus esfuerzos que las
indemnizaciones de partida se corrijan
que
más desfavorecidos
mejoren su situación
quiero con ustedes reconstruir el
impulso de nuestra nación no ceder a las
divisiones al contrario mantener este
rumbo hacia nuestra independencia al
servicio de esta idea tan francesa de la
justicia y abrir tres grandes frentes de
trabajo primero el frente del trabajo
hay resultados inéditos e indiscutibles
y es el fruto de las transformaciones de
estos últimos años y el esfuerzo de
todos nosotros
si en seis años hemos creado un millón
700 mil empleos para nuestro país
después del éxito del aprendizaje para
nuestros jóvenes Ahora quiero emprender
la reforma del Liceo profesional para
que la mayor parte de nuestros
adolescentes y jóvenes
tengan una formación calificada para el
empleo
También queremos que haya más
beneficiarios del ingreso de solidaridad
activa acompañando a estas personas de
manera concreta en sus vidas también es
necesario pagar mejor el trabajo en seis
años hemos decidido alzas consecuentes y
primas
pero frente a esta ira que se ha
expresado debemos actuar de manera aún
más vigorosa por eso he propuesto
recibir a las organizaciones Patronales
Y sindicales a partir de mañana por la
mañana para las que quieran hacerlo la
puerta siempre estará abierta y esto
para abrir sin ningún living límites sin
ningún tabú una serie de negociaciones
en torno a temas esenciales mejorar los
ingresos de los asalariados hacer
progresar las carreras para compartir
mejor las riquezas mejorar las
condiciones de trabajo encontrar
soluciones para el desgaste profesional
aumentar el trabajo de los seniors y
ayudar a las reconversiones este nuevo
pacto de la vida para el trabajo se
construirá en los próximos meses a
través del diálogo social y a través de
acuerdos muy concretos a nivel nacional
y también más cerca del terreno
allí donde estén las organizaciones
sindicales y Patronales
además por la a través de la red
industrialización crearemos empleos
mejor pagados y encontraremos nuestra
nueva fuerza también hemos tenido allí
resultados tangibles e inéditos en
Francia en varios cantones hay fábricas
nuevas 200 fábricas nuevas en los
últimos dos años nuestro país se había
acostumbrado a la desindustrialización
pero en estos lugares hemos vuelto a
industrializar y somos el país en Europa
más activo en este campo nuestra
economía respetuosa de nuestras tierras
y de nuestros paisajes es una realidad
Ahora que nos permite respetar nuestros
acuerdos con el clima gracias a la
planificación ecológica que
publicaremos de aquí al próximo verano
haremos nuevos esfuerzos en la
agricultura el transporte la energía y
las tecnologías es un marco también
en el cual estaremos mejor preparados
para enfrentar el cambio climático como
entre otras cosas la sequía del verano
también
el otro campo es el del orden
republicano y democrático
no hay libertad sin ley y sin sanción
contra quienes transgreden el derecho de
los demás Con este fin reclutaremos más
de 10.000 magistrados y agentes que
mejoren el funcionamiento de nuestra
justicia También estamos creando nuevas
gendarmerías en nuestros Campos luchar
contra todas las formas de delincuencia
contra todo fraude ya sea social y
fiscal también será parte central de la
acción del gobierno con anuncios fuertes
a partir del mes de mayo también
fortalezaremos el control de la
inmigración ilegal integrando mejor a
quienes en nuestro país
renovar el orden republicano y
democrático significa también que
debemos luchar contra el sentimiento
persistente de que votar ya no serviría
he propuesto junto con el presidente del
senado y de la asamblea nacional y del
Consejo económico y social y ambiental
acciones para mejorar el funcionamiento
de nuestras instituciones
de hecho ya lo hicimos con la convención
ciudadana sobre el fin de vida
el último frente de trabajo es el del
Progreso un progreso para vivir mejor
quiero que cada uno de ustedes
se encuentre la certeza de que los
nuestros hijos podrán vivir mejor
desde los más pequeños Hasta los más
grandes
para eso habrá una reforma de la
educación nuestra escuela será una de
las mejores de Europa habrá un cambio
radical mejor remuneración de Los
docentes mejor acompañamiento de los
alumnos más deporte en el colegio habrá
un cambio para los padres
que verán como Los docentes ausentes
serán reemplazados inmediatamente
desde hace seis años 11 millones de
franceses y francesas
se han beneficiado de las reformas en el
campo del servicio de salud para
dentistería y para oftalmología de aquí
a fines de este año 600 mil pacientes
que tienen enfermedades crónicas si no
tienen médicos tratantes Ya los tendrán
y de aquí a fines del año entrante
habremos
descongestionado todos nuestros
servicios de urgencias y para quienes
vivían en barrios desfavorecidos en
zonas Rurales y en nuestros territorios
de ultramar para todos ellos
encontraremos soluciones concretas para
mejorar la vida cotidiana
queridos y queridas compatriotas Todos
hemos enfrentado juntos la epidemia Hay
tantas crisis en los últimos años
siempre he querido liberar las energías
he protegido a los más débiles
dado prioridad a la unidad de nuestro
país el único la única guía es el
interés de la nación y ese mismo
espíritu de responsabilidad nos debe
mover en el momento en que tenemos que
enfrentarlos desafíos del cambio
climático del envejecimiento de los
cambios geopolíticos revoluciones
tecnológicas como la Inteligencia
artificial y los algoritmos
hace cuatro años recuerdo casi dia
riamente
hablaba de la misma manera entre ustedes
Nuestra Señora de París se acababa de
incendiar y les aseguré desde el día
siguiente que la reconstruiríamos en
cinco años
cuántas cosas no me dijeron en ese
momento todos los comentaristas nos
decían eso es imposible porque ese rumbo
Porque esa meta tan imposible y yo dije
no pues vamos a hacerlos porque se toma
una decisión pero sobre todo lo vamos a
lograr porque todos los días todo se
movilizaron
para cumplir esta meta todos en todo el
país
trabajamos juntos para esta
reconstrucción y lo mismo Será para los
grandes frentes de trabajo en la nación
por eso llamo a todas las fuerzas de
buena voluntad
nuestras madres nuestros sindicatos
nuestras fuerzas políticas quiero
asociarlos desde el mes de mayo lanzando
nuevas coaliciones de alianzas sobre las
bases sólidas del Consejo Nacional de la
muy cerca del terreno
cada uno de ustedes tiene un papel para
jugar se requiere menos burocracia más
libertad de acción más experimentación
más poder de iniciativa a la escala de
nuestras vidas es este impulso nacional
en el que yo creo y estos tres frentes
de trabajo prioritarios constituyen la
hoja de ruta del gobierno que la primera
ministra les explicará detalladamente a
partir de la semana entrante
estas estos tres frentes de trabajo
deben reunir a los principales
responsables de la nación y yo me
involucraré personalmente
en el primer balance también estaré
presente todos los días un días de
tranquilización ambición y acción al
servicio de Francia es es nuestro deber
Confío en ustedes Confío en todos
nosotros para que lo logremos viva la
República viva Francia
[Música]